le jeu vidéo est la première industrie
culturelle en france en termes de
chiffre d'affaires le marché devant
celui du cinéma et de la musique et les
yvelines en étant des territoires clés
selon une étude du centre régional
d'observation du commerce de l'industrie
et des services
le grossiste 81 % des effectifs sont
situés en île de france et près de la
moitié d'entre eux dans notre
département
l'éditeur de world of warcraft blizzard
a par exemple décidé d'installer ses
locaux à versailles
l'année dernière la ville avait
accueilli des fans de tout le pays pour
le lancement mondial du jeu vidéo
starcraft 2 vincent dondaine un travail
dans le jeu vidéo depuis 14 ans jusqu'en
2008 il travaillait pour vivendi games
mobile à vélizy mais l'entreprise a
fusionné à l'époque avait qu'activision
sans emploi il décide de fonder avec
d'anciens collègues sa propre société du
leap x au démarrage on était vraiment
parti pour créer un studio de
développement est très vite ce qui s'est
passé sur l'app store c'est qu'on a eu
un succès qui était hysteria project est
immédiatement derrière my brute de fil
en aiguille moi je me suis dit pendant
sept ans avant j'avais fait de l'édition
pourquoi pas reproduire c'est le bon
moment il ya une fenêtre
cette fenêtre il faut s'engouffrer
maintenant puisque après quand c'est
plus l'heure c'est plus l'heure hong
kong a été est finalement petit à petit
on est venu de seulement producteurs de
contenus un éditeur et pour des tiers et
maintenant on travaille avec on va dire
environ une centaine de développeurs car
il ya cinq ans le marché des jeux vidéo
physique décline au profit des jeux pour
smartphones ou tablettes
bulkypix est positionné à temps elle
enregistre chaque année de 100 à 200 %
de croissance et espère atteindre en
2013 5 millions de chiffre d'affaires
dans ces bureaux ont créé de nouveaux
jeux tout part d'un concept des game
designers prépare un document de base
avec règles du jeu personnages et
niveaux des graphistes conçoivent alors
l'univers et les décors et les
programmeurs de leur côté se charge de
la partie technique et les algorithmes
une fois qu'on a identifié le jeu et
qu'on sait où on veut aller on fait les
estimations chacun dans les corps de
métier et ensuite on part en production
donc les graphistes et une bonne vision
de l'univers graphique du jeu et vont du
coup faire les dessins faire les
animations modéliser les personnages le
game designer lui va faire ses réglages
faire ces niveaux et les programmeurs
nous on est un peu en bout de chaîne
puisqu'on va intégrer à la fois les
réglages du game design les niveaux du
game design et les ressources graphiques
fait par les graphistes pour rassembler
tout ça est arrivé à faire un jeu ou une
application derniers jeux développés
astérix mega bass bulkypix et réalise
également des jeux en coédition voir
pour le compte d'autres entreprises
autres activités de la société l'édition
de jeux vidéo
elles indiquent recevoir de 15 à 20 jeux
par jour leurs plus values les rendre
visible la réalité c'est que quand un
jeu sort sur sur l'app store ou sur les
smartphones et tablettes
il y en a un sur dix qui va qu'il va
réussir ne serait-ce qu'à ceux
comptabilisés
donc ça veut dire que il ya énormément
de petites sociétés qui vont aller au
casse pipe et qui vont avoir investi
leur argent
pas parce que le jeu n est pas bon mais
parce qu'ils n'auront pas la visibilité
suffisante à apporter au jeu donc nous
c'est la valeur ajoutée de bulles
typique c'est de repérer les jeux de
qualité est d'être capable de leur
donner une visibilité auprès d'apple
auprès de google et des différentes
plates formes digitales pour ce faire
bulkypix compte sur une bonne étude de
marché et une bonne communication grâce
à son carnet de onze mille journalistes
son réseau de professionnels du marché
mais aussi ses relations avec google et
apple
une équipe est chargée du marketing et
du business development et d'ailleurs
situé à san francisco mais surtout il
faut choisir le bon âge comme on les met
dehors du disque à côté de ça y est les
labels indépendants nous on est le label
indépendant sur les smartphones et
tablettes et dans digital en général
donc on essaye de trouver des jeux qui
ont une patte quelque chose de vraiment
différent et comme par exemple un jeu
que l'on a senti la semaine dernière qui
s'appelle typewriter et qui est numéro
un sur l'app store iphone et ipad
donc c'est un jeu sur la typographie
c'est le genre d'expérience qu'on essaye
de trouver typewriter était toute cette
semaine numéro
des applications payantes sur l'apple
store si les français sont attirés par
les jeux vidéo le sont illégalement par
les métiers de ce secteur en ile de
france on dénombre une trentaine de
formations attrapé l'école troisième a
ouvert en 2011 une formation spécifique
elle propose de former des étudiants aux
arts numériques puis de se spécialiser
en jeu vidéo ou en cinéma d'animation
la première promotion sortira cette
année mais sur les 30 élèves seuls 10
ont choisi la spécialité jeux vidéo a
priori sont pas ils n'arrivent pas en
disant mon rêve c'est le jeu vidéo pas
forcément ils sont très très intéressé
par le cinéma par le cinéma 3d parler
production de dreamworks
walt disney des américains aussi ce qui
se fait en france vraiment je suis
méchant des choses comme ça et puis pour
beaucoup d'entre eux en fait c'est une
découverte parce qu'il joue joue
beaucoup mais de jouer à passer derrière
il ya tout un monde et ça prendra un
petit peu de temps pour se rendre compte
de ce que c'est enfin donc le jeu vidéo
william fait partie de ces élèves qui
joue mais qui aime également les dessous
des jeux vidéo
on va dire que jeux vidéo ça permet une
interaction ça permet de raconter une
histoire mais également de faire
interagir spectateurs ça lui permet de
découvrir l'univers avec ses propres
yeux
mais on va également pour le guider ma
pour aller mettre des énigmes en pour le
piéger donc c'est une partie très
intéressant de troupes dans ce jeu vidéo
qu'on a pensé ma d'animations durant ces
trois années williams a appris les bases
académiques
le dessin classique la perspective la
lumière la scénographie puis les bases
de la 2d de la 3d comme sur ses
logiciels
c'est peut-être la modéliser une fois on
la dupliquer avec différentes
expressions de visage toujours avec le
même nombre de points
et à chaque fois on a demandé à cette
tête sur la contrainte par exemple
circonspect d'avoir l'expression qui a
été modélisé et donc du coup il permet
d'avoir un mort d'une modification entre
les deux avec toutes les transitions
si tu permets comme ça d'animer plus
simplement on parle hébreu triste dans
cette suite
ce passionné de jeux vidéo ne se fait
pas de souci pour son avenir
il est persuadé qu'il y aura de la place
pour les jeunes pourtant en france on ne
compte que cinq mille personnes dans ce
secteur mais les choses pourraient
évoluer c'est si on se limite vraiment
au secteur du vidéo ludique c'est à dire
du divertissement
mais le jeu couvrent des secteurs
beaucoup plus vaste que ça le jeu coût
des secteurs en entreprise dans tout les
secteurs de l'industrie sur le serious
game le jeu est en train de pénétrer
dans les musées aujourd'hui on fait plus
une exposition fait un parcours
d'exposition c'est à dire qu'on fait
appel à quelque chose qui est du domaine
du jeu de tourner à gauche tourner à
droite que va-t-il se passer
donc je crois que dans les débouchés il
faut pas se contenter de penser ou
sociétés ou jeux mobiles il faut voir
que c'est une mode d'interaction qui
devient indispensable dans nos sociétés
quel que soit le secteur dans lequel
vous évoluez bulkypix produit déjà jeux
et applications pour des marques ou des
agences de communication
l'autre diversification de ce marché
repose sur les nouveaux supports ps4
xbox one et bien d'autres encore
tout le monde disait le pc morts alors
que la plateforme steam est en train
d'exploser et ils ont annoncé ce qu'ils
appellent estime machine ce qui sont des
plus ni moins que des groupes et 7
salons qui vont être disponible l'année
prochaine et après il ya des choses un
petit peu plus spécial qui arrivent
comme des lunettes de réalité virtuelle
l'oculus rift qui vont annoncer les
grosses révolutions dans le jeu vidéo et
c'est pareil on est déjà très clairement
en train de regarder ce qu'on peut faire
donc je dirais que on est au début d'un
nouveau cycle économique et c'est un
petit peu ça le jeu vidéo là on était un
peu
dans la grosse crise et fin de cycle et
là on a toutes les portes qui sont
ouverts de vendre de petites révolutions
qui ouvre bien des perspectives
le gouvernement souhaite d'ailleurs
soutenir ce secteur
fleur pellerin ministre délégué à
l'économie numérique multiplie les
annonces création de quartier numérique
partenariat avec ubisoft dont une aide
financière de 3 5 millions pour l'état
et création d'un groupe de travail au
sénat ce dernier préconise notamment de
renforcer l'offre de capital-risque à
ces entreprises